[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the White House held
what they described as a listening
session today we're survivors of last
week's Florida shooting gathered with
the parents of children killed in
previous shootings to discuss what the
country ought to be doing going forward
here some of what was said we must
create a culture of connectedness we
must create a culture in which our
classmates become our friends every
single one of these school shootings
have been from young men who are
disconnected one school shooting and we
should have fixed it and I'm pissed
because my god I'm not gonna see again I
want to feel safe at school you know
senior year and junior big years for me
when I turn my academics around started
connecting with teachers and I started
actually enjoying school and now I don't
know how I'm ever gonna step foot on
that place again the teacher would have
a concealed gun on them they'd go for
special training and they would be there
and you would no longer have a gun-free
zone gun-free zone to a maniac because
they're all cowards a gun-free zone is
let's go in and let's attack because
bullets aren't coming back at us you
feel for those kids and their families
it seems likely as a political matter
that some form of gun control may be
coming the White House has signaled
support for stricter background checks
and a federal ban on bump stocks that's
not even close to what many on the Left
are demanding you saw some of those
demands today at widely televised gun
control rallies in Florida some of those
in attendance were kids from Stoneham
Douglass High School in parkland and
that should not be surprising it's
understandable people become political
activists all the time in response to
tragedies that's their right nobody
ought to attack them for it we're
certainly not attacking them we never
would we assume they have the best
motives most of us have the best motives
almost everybody's against school
shootings the question is what do you do
about them now if you watch a lot of
cable no news you know that the answer
is simple you simply stop taking money
from the NRA and you do something about
guns not anything specific just
something but first you have to defeat
the evil conservatives who love school
massacres once you do that the violence
will go away like magic
and so the demagogues and the other
channels are telling you they use the
traumatized children of parkland as a
human shield ask them what they're
calling for ask them to describe these
policies will supposedly fix everything
and these childless news anchors screech
that you're attacking the children it's
funny every January thousands of other
children come to Washington for the
march on life like the kids from
Parkland they're against killing some of
them have had abortions a few of them
have survived abortions do the media
hold these kids up as the last word on
the subject
do they attack anyone who questions them
please a lot of news outlets don't even
bother to cover that March at all
all kids at any March just like all
Americans have a right to talk and to do
so in public to give their opinions
anywhere including on television unlike
many on the Left we support that right
unequivocally in every case but the rest
of us also have a right to add our
voices to the conversation we have an
obligation to do that because we all
have a stake in this country's laws then
the truth is this is a remarkably
complicated subject that's why we
haven't fixed it yet any answer has to
balance our need for safety with respect
for the civil rights of individuals and
an acknowledgement that this is a
constitutional republic it's not the set
of Morning Joe
for example pretty much everybody agrees
that people with mental illness should
not have firearms it sounds simple okay
but what do you do then with the more
than 400,000 Iraq and Afghanistan vets
who have received a diagnosis of PTSD
that's a mental disorder should they
lose their rights to gun ownership
because they were injured by war all of
a sudden it's not so simple
how about domestic abusers nobody thinks
they should have guns we don't obviously
but what if they haven't been convicted
of anything yet can you strip rights
from somebody who is legally innocent
and if you can take their gun rights
away how about their voting rights or
their free speech speech rights we're
not sure of the answers to those
but we're positive they are real
questions that need to be debated and
considered by smart people sincerely
trying
to make the country better the medias
creatures are not helping they're
telling us it's a simple fix as long as
you care enough that's a lie and they're
using children to tell that lie spare us
we're for the children were not for you
congressman Jim Himes is a Democrat
represents Connecticut he joins us
tonight and congressman unlike a lot of
people you've been specific about what
you wanted I admire that you were on CNN
on Monday and you said and I'm quoting
now we want to be no different from
Canada or Australia or Great Britain so
in Australia and you hear this a lot
from the left 650,000 guns were
confiscated from citizens and that's
what you're calling for who would do
that who would take those guns in this
country no that's that's not what I'm
calling for chucker
Australia is a pretty good example
because after the massacre of 35 of its
citizens in Port Arthur in 1996 they
implemented a whole series and you're
yeah I don't usually agree with you
Tucker but you're right this is a
complicated problem that won't get
solved certainly not by the media on
either side but it will get solved over
time not perfectly by lots of measures
some of which we're tried by Australia
now Australia doesn't have a second
amendment so they're not the best
example but we do know that if we could
get universal background check no matter
where you buy a gun you get a background
check we do know that if you could find
a way and I admit that it is complicated
with with rights to make sure that
people with temporary restraining orders
temporarily give up their weapons if you
could do a whole bunch of those things
there is no question that like Australia
we could see our gun violence in this
country plummet well there there is a
question about that I mean we don't
actually know and we have the assault
weapons ban of 1994 and it seemed like
it would reduce killings and it didn't
we know that conclusively so you're
never quite sure with the effect is but
you twice pointed to Australia as a
model for gun policy here so what
specifically about Australia again a
country that confiscated its citizens
guns by the hundreds of thousands what
specifically did they do that we should
yeah you can keep using the word
confiscation but they did that's no
that's not calling for it is also a fact
that they instituted a mandatory waiting
period for the purchase of a gun it is
also a fact that they instituted
a universal background check two things
that we don't have in this country that
might be considered constitutional so
you can leave the confiscation behind
because that's not what anybody that was
but that was the essence that was the
essence of what they did you're not
allowed to own a gun in Australia except
under circumstances where the government
says you've somehow got a right to is
same with Great Britain you all you
pointed to Great Britain in Great
Britain you're not allowed to own a gun
you have to prove that you should be
allowed to have one are you calling for
that well no I'm not in both of those
countries in the absence of a second
Amendment you're right you have to show
a cause a reason to have a gun we have a
Second Amendment in this country which
you may be surprised to hear I support
so what does it sound like to require
the citizens well you can say that as
much as you want Tucker but if I'm just
saying it was in response to what you
said what I'm calling for is what by the
way the president I'm not usually in the
habit of praising the president what the
president has said he's willing to
consider things like tightening up the
background check things like
restrictions on technology like bump
stocks nobody's calling for confiscation
or for everything they do in Australia
in Great Britain
just to be clear don't paint well so
don't don't point me don't paint me as a
demagogue you just said this two days
ago one's CNN and you pointed
specifically to a country that got rid
of gun violence because it got rid of
guns so I think it's a fair question for
me to ask when you point to Australia
why are you not calling for confiscation
because that's the core thing they did
first of all Australia did not get rid
of guns there are still a lot of guns of
Australia in Australia there are plenty
of guns in Canada there are plenty of
guns in the United Kingdom these are
these are countries that are different
than our own but no they did not get rid
of guns in any one of those countries so
but they haven't keep talking about
Australia I never call overcome you're
the one who was talking about Australia
not me okay so I let me just say this
those countries officer of the universal
model have Universal gun registration
one way Australia is a good model in one
way which was that after a tragedy 35
people dead in Port Arthur they got
together the Prime Minister and six
states got together and said let's pass
a package of gun safety changes that
will reduce violence now not all of
those changes would apply in the United
States or not I'm not looking for that
like taking them away by force from the
population so let me ask you this those
countries also again you can keep doing
this so that's not what
I'm sorry I know a lot about this and
that was the whole point of the bill so
and you must know that was and that was
a part of the bill that I'm not calling
for and frankly mother that was calling
for compensation okay so let me ask you
this
those countries all have all have
Universal gun registration you own a gun
you have to register with the government
are you for that you know they actually
cancelled the universal gun registration
in Australia because they felt that it
was more of a burden on legal gun owners
than it was on people he foreign what I
know I'm not necessarily for in the
United States I am for everybody having
a background check I am for people with
temporary restraining orders temporarily
giving up their guns I am for a limit on
the size of the magazine that you can
use things that we've done here in the
state of Connecticut which have been
constitutional and have not resulted in
people second amendment I was wondering
this today so you work up on Capitol
Hill surrounded by armed guards do you
think they have too many guns and do you
believe that their magazines to hold too
many rounds and if not why not
Tucker nice try you're not going to be a
part hmm sir you feel safe with a lot of
people with high-capacity magazines but
I'm not allowed to have them in my house
to protect my family cuz why explain it
slowly okay okay all right let's explain
that that's an absurd argument but let
me agree with you that I would be too I
would be perfectly happy with the
general public having the same firearms
that the Capitol Police have if the
general public were like Capitol Police
required undergo a criminal check
required to recertify themselves every
single year for the use of those
firearms and personally accountable and
professionally accountable for how
they're used so if you're willing to put
all of those restrictions on the general
public's right to firearms which is what
the Catholic you have which you can have
no
otherwise sign this rescue let me ask
you something one last question so
because some of us are confused by the
details here you endorsed the most
recent iteration of the assault weapons
ban and in that there are a 9 I've asked
this question of a lot of lawmakers all
me interested to see your response in
that it would ban rifles that have
something called a barrel shroud those
would be a little why what does a barrel
shredding why would you ban it so a
barrel shroud as you probably know
because you can talk to your other
guests about it is a covering on the
barrel of a gun that allows you to hold
that gun when the barrel has overheated
because of multiple rounds being fired
sprouts that's right right okay so we
agree on that now I'm not all that
worked up over barrel shrouds and I'm
not even interested really in going the
route of saying that an assault weapon
ban will solve our problems I happen to
support a ban on technology that allows
you to get squeezed off 20 or 30 rounds
in a minute or two now I understand that
was supported a bill that would have
banned that in pistol grips and folding
stocks and banette lugs and all these
things that are irrelevant it makes you
seem not serious if you support
something like that you know lots of
states have passed assault weapons ban I
heard you talking about you know the
desire of the populous earlier a lot
that lots of states have implemented
including my own of Connecticut assault
when the ban now what I'm going to tell
you is that the number of people who die
in this country as a result of assault
weapons though they make the headlines
that is a relatively small person
nonetheless I don't want people to have
guns that allow them and most police
officers don't want people to have guns
that allow them to squeeze off 20 or 30
rounds very rapidly without without
reloading look you asked about barrel
shrouds I'm here I think I'll let you
unpack it all and I appreciate your
willingness to come out and explain your
views on this thank you very much
okay Thank You Tucker